[Applause]
durant
now and if it's on tucker that's going
to be his fourth
as tucker and durant get into each
other's face
tucker now yelling at kyrie irving
if you're tucker you've got to be smart
okay it's going to be a double technical
foul you don't want to pick up another
one
and be ejected out of this ballgame yeah
they'll be double technicals i wonder
if they might hand out another one for a
third player who came in
[Applause]
[Music]
and that's a foul that's gonna be his
fourth and durant said something right
after that now
face to face
that was appeared to be a security
coming in that
had to shove there see not i think
it's hard to tell if tucker's yelling at
irving or the security guard who came
barreling in
well one of those i think it's a double
technical foul
yo that that's for sure and i think in
security you have to be security and
make sure you're not elevating
the issue as opposed to controlling it
so these these two texas longhorns who
have a terrific relationship
the emotion of the playoffs taking over
security did a bad job you won't come in
pushing and shoving yeah
you're right mark
but everybody overreacts that was like
nothing you don't need five security
officers
for what nothing they call a personal
foul
on pj tucker
now has four fouls and they each get
a check that goes through a double
technical which doesn't result in any
shots
but the rule of course if you get a
second technical foul that's automatic
ejection on the net i'm going right back
to kevin durant
he's getting the basketball and i'm
playing through him
wearing a mic for sound how about the
defense
cj tucker trying to make kevin durant a
little uncomfortable
at times being successful but some of
these like you mentioned are
it's good defense but these are
very very makeable shots by durant and
here's the one
that led to the overreaction by a swarm
of security guards
let's check in with lisa yeah mike well
pj tucker was talking to reporters
yesterday about how difficult it is to
play
to defend kevin durant without fouling
him and he was giving him
giving durant so much respect maybe too
much respect publicly some have said
tucker said that look duran is going to
score he's probably one of the best
scorers
ever to play the game i've just got to
try to make it as tough
as possible but you're not going to wear
it
you're not going to shut him down